Castle Hill primary school in Beijing
Stoke is currently educating 30 children
who arrive they're vulnerable
or have parents who are key workers on
June the 1st the numbers will increase
to a hundred free lockdown they had 500
but even at a fifth of capacity social
distancing will be a challenge we've -
to do a survey with her parents and I
think it's about 40% who wants to enter
children back
so we'll again we'll be phasing it we'll
monitor it and we'll see how effectively
we're integrating children if it was a
larger number that it would present a
really significant challenge so in a way
you're helped by the fact that some of
the parents aren't going to send their
kids back if it's gradual I think I
cannot think of a school in the country
that B ought to absorb all the children
come back tomorrow Friday the 20th of
March the date schools closed still on
the whiteboard and this is a classroom
of yesterday with all the tables bunched
together you'd have 30 children in this
classroom but next door is the classroom
of the future this school will only
allow 6 pupils per room now and that
means that for the same number of
children you'd actually need five
classrooms to educate them Hampshire
County Council says all their schools
have been asked to prepare for the
partial return of pupils on June the 1st
as the government has asked but even
though this council isn't rebelling
parents and children have mixed feelings
for me it's probably going to be a good
thing because my children have
additional needs so being out of routine
for them has been really tricky I would
probably for grace be happy if we just
all took a little bit of a step back and
actually just took a bit of a reality
check and keep things on hold it's all
about you grace I think I should still
work from home until kovat is almost
completely gone Sammy and Daisy won't be
returning to primary school on June the
1st their mom Jackie is a secondary
teacher herself and don't you think it's
safe I am worried that they will bring
it home I suffer as well with
respiratory issues myself and I just
don't understand how the socially
distancing thing is going to work
Jackie's husband is a headmaster of this
Basingstoke Secondary School Brighton
Hill they're preparing for a return of
year tens he chairs the Headmaster's
group who discussed the issue last night
some schools have got a lot of
vulnerable students in already and
children of key workers which means that
a lot of their physical space is taken
up by those children already to then
parachute in the whole of year 10 on top
of that it's just not going to be
possible for them so we've all got
different plans they do share some
similarities but we're all doing the
best that we possibly can for our own
individual communities a survey of year
10 parents that this school found only
three-quarters would send their kids
back so it's not just the teachers
unions of the council's who need
convincing even when schools are opening
their doors not everyone will come Jason
Ferrell Sky News